[Musique]
pascaline ponama j'ai 44 ans je suis né
et j'ai grandi à saint benoît
aujourd'hui je suis donc directrice de
la fédération mais titre s c'est une
jeune structure qu'on a créé en 2010 est
pour venir en aide aux acteurs qui
travaillent les fibres végétales le show
calva quoi la paille shoe bomber rukoko
vétiver etc j'ai fait un parcours
littéraire dans ma formation
et puis j'ai découvert le bénévolat
associatif
j'ai commencé d'abord dans le
développement de quartiers j'ai évolué
dans l'accompagnement socioprofessionnel
donc des publics en difficulté et puis
j'ai voulu comprendre le milieu
économique parce que j'ai trouvé que le
milieu social était souvent déconnectés
du monde économique et je me suis
retrouvé à a dirigé une structure
d'accompagnement à la création
d'entreprise donc la couveuse pendant
une dizaine d'années je me suis forcée
en tout cas à essayer de créer des
passerelles entre le monde de
l'insertion et le monde économique
donc j'ai ensuite évolué en créant mon
entreprise dans l'ingénierie de projets
avec une spécialisation dans le champ de
l'économie sociale et solidaire puisque
c'est ça c'est mon dada en fait je n'ai
pas compris en fait tout dans mon
parcours pourquoi on avait autant de
monde qui galérait pourquoi alors de
l'autre côté il y aurait
des activités à développer et qu'on ne
sait pas le faire
quand je suis confronté à des cas
d'injustice que ce soit pour moi ou pour
les autres
j'ai tendance à réagir c'est ce qui a
aussi motivé mon implication dans le
milieu associatif en tant que bénévole
en tant que militante
on dit de moi aussi que je suis quand
même quelqu'un d'assez persévérant donc
je ne lâche pas souvent la faire quand
voilà quand j'ai une idée en tête c'est
ce qui me permet aussi de
contribuer efficacement à développer des
projets
[Musique]
notre enjeu dans notre filière des
fibres végétales c'est de changer le
regard du réunionnais sur ce patrimoine
que les gens arrêtent de d'être resté
seul dans leurs droits si nous sommes
nombreux
nous aurons une écoute peut être plus
attentive de la part des collectivités
des institutions en tout cas nous
l'espérons